FEMALE SPEAKER: She
is the lead designer
of Google Class, one of the
products from Google X Group.
She joined the
Glass team in 2011
when the prototype was still a
phone attached to a scuba mask.
And she has since
guided the team
to iterate towards the current
minimalist design, which
looks really fashionable
and has, I think,
been noticed by a lot
of designers and awards.
Prior to joining Google,
Isabelle worked at Fuseproject,
designing a wide variety of
products ranging from the Nook
Color, Samsung televisions,
to Swarovski exhibitions,
and eyewear for
children in third world.
She has also designed
several furniture exhibits,
which have been exhibited
at Milan Furniture Fair.
Isabelle grew up in Sweden
and was influenced early on
by Scandinavian
minimalist design.
Her ultimate goal
as a designer is
to make peoples' lives
easier and more beautiful.
Sounds very familiar to
[INAUDIBLE] mission too.
And without further
ado, let's start
watching a video of Isabelle.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-OK.
So I'm going to
engage the system.
[BEEP BEEP]
And now the car is in control.
I didn't even imagine
that self-driving cars
would exist in my lifetime.
So to know that the
technology exists,
and I get to work on it
firsthand is pretty incredible.
-At Google X, we really take
breakthrough technologies
and apply them in
areas where we think
it could really
transform the world.
-So part of it is
moonshot thinking,
setting a really amazing goal
that is really inspiring,
that could be possible,
but feels almost
like science fiction.
-Well, especially at Google
X, is first and foremost
the people.
-When I first heard about
the job, I was thinking,
how would I fit in at Google X?
Coming here, I didn't
feel odd at all,
because everybody's
odd in their own way.
-So I came to Google X
actually through a bit
of circuitous route.
I went to grad school
and got my Ph.D.
In a field of nanophotonics.
So basically, I went
from microphotonics
to nanophotonics.
-It's certainly
common in companies
around here in Silicon Valley
that the engineering workforce
is very largely male.
And maybe they have 10% women,
or 20%, or something like that.
We'd like to get to 50% women.
-If we have just
men and not women,
if we have just people
of a particular race,
or just of a different
particular background,
or from a particular
country, that's
not going to be helpful,
because we're not
going to think of the
breakthrough things.
-It's by harnessing all
this communal creativity,
if you will, that we're
able to do what we do.
-What we're really looking
for is passionate people
who love what they
do and love to work
on high-impact projects
that have a technology
angle to them.
-And you know, we make
a little prototype,
and then you're like, yes.
Then I run around
the entire office
and show it off to everybody.
And I'm like, oh, look at this.
This is so cool.
-I'm an optics person.
I'm a hardware engineer.
If you think that you're
in this very narrow field
and there's no opportunity, and
Google being mostly a software
company, you might be
surprised like I was.
-I came to Google X
fresh out of school.
I have friends that go to
work, and it's just a job.
But here, this is so
much more than that.
-This is where we were about
one and a half years ago when
I first started.
It's literally a phone
stuck next to your head.
Now, we are here.
-Knowing that when
I come to work,
I'm doing something
that's making history
definitely puts a
smile on my face
and gets me excited to come
to work every single day.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ISABELLE OLSSON: Hi, everybody.
Thank you for having me.
I'd like to talk
a little bit today
about staying uncomfortable.
I think this is a good
example of doing just that,
being in front of so many
talented women in tech.
It's pretty incredible.
So I hope I have something
that can inspire you.
I'm not really sure,
but I'll do my best.
So I think, generally in
life, we strive for comfort,
trying to finding the perfect
home, or a perfect partner,
and trying to be
really comfortable.
And I think in our
careers and what
has helped me is to
do the very opposite,
is to put yourself in situations
where you are really, really
uncomfortable.
I think that pushes
you to the next level.
And I think that's why
I moved to San Francisco
about five years ago.
I had a great life in Sweden.
Bunch of friends,
family were designing
for [INAUDIBLE], and
exhibiting things,
and just having kind
of an easy life.
So then I thought, I think I
can have more impact than that.
And just so much exciting things
going on in San Francisco,
so I thought, why don't
I just try and go there?
Just drop everything, and
move into a little shoebox,
and pay thousands of dollars
that I didn't have, and just
not being able to speak
the language properly,
and into a tech world.
I'm really not from tech.
I've always loved tinkering
and building things.
But when I moved here, I
didn't have a smartphone.
I hardly knew what a
flat-screen TV was.
And all of a sudden, I was
in this center of tech.
And I thought, what
did I get myself into?
I'm crazy.
And I remember my first
day at Fuseproject,
which was a design consultancy
that I started working at.
And the project was to design
the next-generation tablet,
and I'm like, what is a tablet?
[LAUGHTER]
I had no concept of it.
So I started to look for
inspiration in things
that I love, things
that, I think, make
life more beautiful, like
furniture or jewelry,
and I pinned my little
pictures up on the wall.
And then I looked around and
I saw all the dude pictures,
and it was just
full of computers.
There was just
computers on the wall,
and then I had some
rings and a little chair.
And I thought, gosh, this is
really embarrassing right now.
I really don't know
what I'm doing.
But the cool thing was that
the art director was like,
take down all the computers.
This is where we're going
and really taking inspiration
from something that
is not familiar.
And that was the first
moment since I moved here
when I realized is, it's
good to be different,
and it's good to
be uncomfortable.
So I worked there for a few
years, and it was amazing,
and I was getting more
and more comfortable.
Not good.
So when I got a call from
Google, I thought, Google?
Do you make-- you
don't make things.
It's on the computer,
the stuff that I
don't know so much about.
But then she said,
well, you know,
we're working on things
like self-driving cars.
Self-driving cars?
She's like, yeah, you
probably heard about it.
I was like, yeah, totally.
I definitely heard about that.
Not.
But I thought, OK,
I'll take the meeting.
This is interesting.
Let's get a little
uncomfortable.
And It definitely was.
I'm sure you've heard about
the Google hiring process.
And you're stuck in a room for
10 hours straight and people
asking you really
strange questions.
And I didn't meet one designer.
So I thought, what
would I do here?
There were optical engineers,
and mechanical engineers,
and UX people, and everybody
except for "my kind."
And also the only
woman, of course.
So I thought, yeah,
yeah, I'll do this.
I'll take this job because it
made me really uncomfortable.
Oh, and did I mention?
They wouldn't tell me what
I was going to work on.
[LAUGHTER]
So you saw this in the video.
But on my first day,
that's when I found out
what I was going to work
on, and they showed me this.
And that was uncomfortable, not
exactly what I was going for.
And I saw this, and it was a
room full of software engineers
on their computers, and they
were actually using this.
I don't know how really,
and this is-- I can't even.
And I'm going to put it
back in my Chanel box here.
But I got really
excited about the vision
that was underlying
around all this tech.
So my job was to, and
this is, quote, my brief,
"make Glass comfortable
and beautiful."
So I thought I could
talk to you a little bit
about my approach in
trying to do that.
Yeah, so this is
what we see today.
Again, it's very early days.
It's Explorer Edition.
We're excited about
where we came from
and where we are today.
But obviously, I'm
already working on
like the v5 or something.
But it's pretty cool.
But it's sometimes-- and I
need to remind myself too
because you kind of start
getting like, things are not
getting smaller.
Why are we not
getting further ahead?
And then I have to
put on this prototype
and just walk around in the
office and make people laugh.
So yeah.
So here's Joe.
He's my product engineer I'm
working really closely with,
and this is a model.
So it's not a fair
comparison really.
[LAUGHTER]
But for impact, it
makes a lot of sense.
So I think when you're in this
really, really uncomfortable
situation as you have
this incredibly hard task,
someone is asking you to make
something impossible basically.
Like, how would you make that
comfortable and beautiful?
It just doesn't make sense.
So what I try to always do
is set up design principles.
And I think even if I'm
talking about design
in this specific
case, I think it
applies to a lot of professions.
And it's really about setting
out, what are the key goals?
What are the key
goals that we always
have to filter a
decision through,
because the messy process?
If you're trying to create
something really amazing,
it's very, very
hard to lose track
of what's really important.
Especially with technology,
you continuously
want to add sensors,
and battery life,
and all these things do
to make it even better.
But in the process, you
actually make the problem worse.
So in the case of Glass,
my main design principle
was simplicity.
You see how it can be
this complex thing.
And the thing is,
people really don't
want to know what's
going on on the inside.
People just want for it to work.
So we definitely had
that as a main motto
throughout the process.
The second principle
is lightness.
And I think it's not only
about physical lightness
but visual lightness, too.
There was another early
prototype, the black one
you see here, had the same
components as Glass currently
does, but it looked really,
really techie, and heavy,
and frightening.
So if you guys think Glass
is frightening today, well,
now you see how it
could have been.
And I think the last
principle is scalability.
It's really important to,
from the very beginning,
think about how is this
going to evolve over time?
How can we anticipate
issues that
are going to come along the way?
So in this case, you see the
prescription glasses for Glass.
And it's the same technology,
it's just the frame coming off,
and you can attach
a different frame.
The second method that I'm
using, which is quite obvious,
but I think it's something
that we all could do even more.
I want to do it more.
And it's about visualizing
your ideas, and in this case,
with prototypes.
Here is the snapshot of my desk,
actually, a few months ago.
But it's an incredible
tool, right,
when you were trying
to push the envelope.
Instead of talking about
things, glue things
together and don't be
too fancy about it.
And then here you actually
see an appearance model,
and it looks very,
very similar to Glass.
But this is actually
a non-functional model
that I created two
and a half years ago.
And this is the
Explorer Edition.
So it really shows if
you set a high goal,
and if you inspire your teams
with something concrete,
you can get there, even
though it's hard along the way
and pretty uncomfortable.
And I think what I touched on
before about scalability is
really important.
When you're trying
to do really hard,
difficult things is to
design for evolution.
Anticipate that things
are not going to work out.
Think about ways that
you, from the beginning,
can design in ways of
evolving things over time.
So in the case of
Glass, I mean, yes,
what you have seen
is the core device,
but it's a whole
ecosystem of other things
that we've now been
able to create since we,
from the beginning, anticipated
that one style doesn't fit all.
And this will just continue
to evolve over time.
Yeah, and here you see
Greg, one of the earliest
users of wearable technology.
He used to wear,
not too long ago,
a huge backpack with a
computer in it and cables
strapped all the
way to his head.
But now he can wear his
regular frames in Glass.
Yeah, and here's
another example of how
we design something that
could really be transformed.
So I think one of the
things I'm the most excited
about, beyond just creating
something that I didn't even
think we could do, is
really how now everybody,
not everybody, but
all of our Explorers
and how they're
using the product.
And how inspiring
that is to then go
after the next challenge
of making this something
that could be for everybody.
So we have a lot of
amazing Explorer stories,
and I just wanted to
share a little snapshot
video of that today.
So if you can cue
the video, please.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-My name is Andrew
Vanden Heuvel.
-I'm Alex Blaszczuk.
-I'm Young Guru.
-I'm Bethanie Mattek-Sands.
-This is firefighter
Patrick Jackson.
-Welcome to CERN.
We made it.
-What is a felling ax?
-What song is this?
-"Glass House."
-How long does it take a proton
to travel the whole route?
-Are there bears
in the Catskills?
-Show extraction diagram.
-Unveiling the new
colors for Wimbledon.
-This is my get down time.
-Thank you, brother.
-Take a picture.
-I'll see you guys when
I get back in Michigan.
-This is amazing.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ISABELLE OLSSON: So
that's all I have today.
And remember to
stay uncomfortable.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]